cuál es el campo de pendientes que está
generado por la ecuación diferencial la
deriva de ye con respecto a x es igual a
x
james y bueno como siempre pausa el
vídeo ip si puedes resolverlo por tu
cuenta bien la manera más fácil de
pensar acerca de un campo dependientes
sin necesitar a graficar a mano en este
campo dependientes sería probar un
montón de puntos xy james y luego
encontraría lo que la derivada tendría
que hacer en ese punto y entonces lo que
podemos hacer aquí ya que he dibujado
para nosotros algunos campos
dependientes que son nuestros candidatos
va a ser bueno encontrar que campos
dependientes o dicho de otra manera cuál
de estos diagramas gráficas o campos
dependientes realmente muestran la
pendiente que voy a encontrar en la
siguiente tabla dándole un cierto valor
a x y un cierto valor a jeff así que
permítanme hacer la pequeña tabla voy a
tener por aquí a x y por aquí voy a
tener a gem y porque voy a tener a la
derivada de ya con respecto a x
así que pensemos se me ocurre tomarme
como primer valor no sé qué pasa cuando
x vale 2 y llevarle 2 bueno la derivada
de con respecto a x esto va a ser dos
menos 2 lo cual es simplemente a 0 y
sólo cuando eso veamos nuestras opciones
para ver cuál de las opciones tiene que
en el punto 2,2 la pendiente sea igual a
cero primero podemos empezar con esta de
aquí la primera y si observas aquí esto
no parece hacer cero parece que es menos
1 así que ya en definitiva puedo
descartar esta opción en la segunda la
pendiente parece que es 1 así que
también voy a descartar esta
definitivamente no es cero
esta tercera también parece que es 1 así
que puedo descartarlo
esta cuarta pendiente en el punto 2 2 en
realidad observa aquí si parece tener
una pendiente de 0 así que me está
gustando bastante esta opción la quinta
bueno tiene una pendiente que parece ser
mayor que a 1 en el punto 2 2 así que
también puedo descartarlo
así que parece que esto fue bastante
sencillo deducir si alguna de estas
opciones va a ser el campo dependientes
que nosotros estamos buscando fue muy
fácil ahora podemos decir que es la
cuarta opción ahora para estar
completamente seguros podremos probar
con algunos puntos de más para ver si en
verdad este es el campo de pendientes
así que pensamos qué pasa cuando cuando
x vale 1 de hecho esperan podemos ver
que cuando x e igualdad jem van a
obtener la derivada igual a 0 cuando
estamos en el punto 4 4 entonces la
derivada observa es igual a 0 cuando
estamos en el punto 6 6 la derivada es
igual a 0 y por ejemplo x a camps en el
punto menos 2 menos dos la derivada es
igual a cero así que eso está bien
en todos estos la pendiente 0 entonces
esta opción va bastante bien nos muestra
también eso y luego podremos escoger
algunos puntos arbitrarios digamos que
es lo que va a pasar cuando x vale 4 y
llévale 2 entonces la derivada kim
debería de ser 4 menos
lo cual va a ser 2 así que cuando x vale
4 y llévale 2 en realidad vemos que el
campo de pendiente es perfecto está
indicando una pendiente que parece 2
vamos muy bien y si pensamos en la otra
dirección no sé
digamos que x valga menos 4 y lleva al
ga menos 2
bueno pues tengo menos cuatro menos
menos 2 lo cual va a ser igual a menos 2
y pueden verlo justo aquí cuando x vale
menos 4 y lleva al menos 2 pueden ver
que la pendiente es bastante parecida a
menos 2 así que una vez más incluso
cuando está primera coordenada 22 nos da
la respuesta correcta no está de más
seguir confirmando que nuestra respuesta
sea la respuesta que estamos buscando